[Musique]
comme vous le savez les nouveaux films
star wars forme d'une trilogie qui est
la suite officielle de la toute première
mais vous êtes vous déjà demandé comment
cette toute nouvelle trilogie star wars
pourrait se terminer
eh bien c'est ce que nous allons voir
aujourd'hui avec trois théories
totalement personnelle que je vous
propose
je pense qu'il est évident pour moi que
le premier ordre se fera détruire à la
fin de cette trilogie
mais comment et par qui pourrait-il être
détruit nous pensons forcément un vrai
futur jedi et fine anciens stormtrooper
sans oublier l'udc qui va certainement
rejoindre la cause mais kelly lorraine
dans tout ça nous avons déjà parlé de
nombreuses fois du fait qu'il
retournerait du bon côté mais il se
pourrait que ce dernier trahissent le
suprême leader snow pour revenir du bon
côté rejoindre sa mère les gars qui va
très certainement disparaître mais il
n'est pas impossible que des morts du
côté lumineux fasse surface il se
pourrait aussi fortement que cahill
lorraine se sacrifie face à stoke pour
que aurait puisse donner le dernier coup
est donc donné la victoire au côté
lumineux
je ne sais pas si vous avez déceler ce
que je voulais dire par-là mais
souvenez-vous key lorraine a pour idole
son grand-père dark vador
il est très fortement possible que ce
dernier se rendre compte de ses erreurs
et décide de tuer stock en se sacrifiant
comme dark vador avec dark sidious par
le passé il la connaît son histoire
tout le monde le sait un combat opposant
lumineux contre le mal éclatera un
combat entre l'ukraine et snacks et
possiblement key lorraine qui ne va pas
faire de la figuration
alors défendra-t-il snoeck qu'il a
corrompu et le général ex avec qui ils
n'arrivent pas à s'entendre ou bien
défendre les valeurs que ses parents lui
ont transmis depuis sa naissance
cahill lorraine voit encore le côté
lumineux et même si la fin de star wars
c'est tu nous laisses prétendre qu'il va
devenir encore plus méchant et puissant
ben solo est jeune et influençable et il
se pourrait bien qu'ils répondent à un
appel de détresse de sa mère ou bien
même de ré car oui cette dernière
pourrait très fortement être la fille de
luke skywalker ou du moins faire partie
de la même famille que kay lorraine et
ce dernier souhaiterait alors la
protéger contre le gré de sa propre vie
pour finir sur cette théorie j'ai envie
de vous dire que key lors elle n'a
jamais eu le choix
on lui a imposé de maîtriser le côté
lumineux dès son enfance il n'a pas eu
le choix
key lorraine a donc très certainement
réagit comme un adolescent face à son
père ran qui n'a pas toujours été tendre
avec lui ben a donc voulu se rebeller
face à ses parents mais comme chaque
enfant kharkai lorraine reste aux jeunes
le banque de ses parents ou même s'être
rendu compte de ses bêtises
le fera changer d'avis d'ailleurs à la
fin il est fortement possible de revoir
les apparitions de anakin skywalker et
obi-wan comme à la fin du sis le
grand-père s'adressant à son petit fils
qui aurait fait le bon choix
la touche de fan service serait tout
simplement énorme et puis il se pourrait
que snow connaissent à la quine du moins
ainsi les darses peguis énormément de
possibilités peuvent exister pour la fin
de la saga mais je pense sincèrement que
kay lorraine va voir un rôle clé et que
sa position dans le côté obscur n'est
qu' éphémère
c'est à vous d'en juger dans les
commentaires mais je pense sincèrement
que c'est possible
une théorie qui signerait la fin de la
saga star wars définitivement et si la
fin de star wars 9 serait la fin des
pratiquants de la force
je m'explique je vous rappelle
l'histoire d'anakin ce jeune jedi devenu
très grand site est un élu de la force
anakin a été créé dans le but de ramener
l'équilibré dans ce dernier cependant
même si la fin de star wars 6 signe le
retour de l' équilibre dans la force
il reste cependant un jedi encore en vie
je parle bien évidemment de luke
skywalker
si tous les sites ont été détruits il
reste néanmoins encore un survivant qui
pratiquent encore la force
cela veut donc dire que l' équilibre n'a
pas été restaurée la preuve le kavé pour
but de créer une académie de futurs jedi
cependant l'un d'entre eux s'est rebellé
avec d'autres partisans elles sont
devenues les chevaliers de rennes un
groupe pratiquant le côté obscur qui a
donc détruit les derniers jedi
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
pour terminer définitivement la saga
star wars
il faut qu'il n'y ait plus aucun
pratiquants de la force que cela soit du
côté lumineux ou du côté obscur la fin
du dernier film de la nouvelle saga star
wars pourrait bien alors signer la mort
des derniers jedi comme l'udc et ray et
des pratiquants du côté obscur comme cai
lorraine et snacks
cependant ses limites impossible
pourquoi car les jedi
elle est entre guillemets nouveaux sites
sont les êtres les plus puissants de la
galaxie et les plus redoutés nos qui est
certainement un seigneur sith ou du
moins grand pratiquant du côté obscur et
le dirigeant du premier ordre
de même pour lui qui est une réelle
menace pour ces derniers qui cherche à
tout prix à le
tu es d'où l'existence des chevaliers de
rennes il se pourrait qu'un grand combat
voire même une grande guerre éclate
entre les derniers jedi et les
chevaliers de rennes d'ailleurs le titre
de star wars 8 se nomme les derniers
jedi
nous pouvons alors penser que les
derniers jedi concerne alors nuque
ehret qui va certainement devenir une
grande pratiquante du côté lumineux
néanmoins le terme deux derniers jedi
est un peu gros pour seulement deux
personnes
il serait possible voire fort possible
que d'autres jedi se cachent encore dans
l'univers que cela soit desservi de
cacher ou des survivants de la rébellion
des chevaliers de rennes une grande
bataille pourrait alors se dérouler
entre les deux camps en revanche il se
pourrait fortement que les derniers jedi
et les chevaliers de rennes s'entretuent
et laissant la place aux tout derniers
combats celui qui opposerait et l'udc
si ce dernier n'est pas mort dans le 8
et kayes lorraine et snacks
sans compter la bataille spatiale entre
l'armée du premier ordre et les rebelles
si disney soit définitivement terminée
la saga star wars
le crès noc des cayes lorraine doivent
mourir
sinon l'équilibré ne sera alors jamais
restaurer à part s'il reste un
pratiquant du côté obscur et un
pratiquant du côté lumineux mais qu'il
soit deux ou dix huit le problème reste
le même
ils finissent toujours par s'entretuer
du moins c'est ce que je pense cependant
est ce que disney souhaite réellement
finir la saga star wars
après l'opus 9
et bien la théorie la plus probable
c'est celle que la saga ne sera toujours
pas fini je m'explique je rappelle que
disney a racheté star wars à george
lucas à plus de 4 milliards de dollars
et disney un énorme but avec la saga
star wars et on peut le voir avec la
sortie de rock one et autres spin off
l'argent disney a bien compris l'étendue
que star wars touchait et compte bien
faire de l'argent en produisant de
nombreux films et cela m'étonnerait très
fortement que la saga s'arrête après les
trois films il se pourrait alors que ce
ne soit toujours en vie et en pleine
santé
erez serait toujours à ses trousses avec
un cahier lorraine toujours plus indécis
cependant les star wars ont toujours
fonctionné par trilogie et cela
m'étonnerait que cette histoire dure
plus de 6 épisodes
il est fort probable que snow peur à la
fin de la saga mais nous pourrions avoir
une raie et un fim et un cahier lorraine
beaucoup plus vieux je suis certain
qu'un star wars 10 11 et 12 naîtra un
jour suite à l'engouement de star wars
mais là n'est pas le sujet je vous donne
rendez vous dans une prochaine vidéo
pour en parler
en tout cas le combat contre stoke
durera certainement trois épisodes mais
nous resterons peut-être sur notre faim
car ray fine et key lorraine serait
toujours là à s'affronter et l'udc
aurait peut-être une chance d'être donc
encore là pareil pour les chevaliers de
rennes et peut-être les jedi cacher
cependant nous avons peu de réponses sur
beaucoup de choses de l'histoire star
wars comme ce qu'il s'est passé entre
l'épisode 6 et 7
une prélogie ferait alors peut-être son
apparition une multitude de possibilités
existent pour la fin de cette saga et c3
fin que je vous énumérez sont les plus
probables
à mes yeux cette vidéo est purement
subjective notre prochain mini théorie
traitera de la possibilité d'une
prélogie ou d'une future trilogie suite
à la nouvelle saga star wars
en tout cas j'espère cette vidéo vous
aura plu et je tiens à m'excuser de
l'absence de l'émission trois théories
mais je suis étudiant et j'ai donc de
grosses semaines je vous souhaite que le
meilleur set et argue rock que le liner
soit avec vous
[Musique]